dans le corps les même alvéole vont
servir à stocker du miel du pollen et à
élever les abeilles et le couvent c'est
la première fois que ces visiteurs
découvrent une ruche plus de 40 mille
abeilles vivent à l'intérieur
et si les voir d'aussi prêt peut être
impressionnant les plus jeunes ne
semblent pas effrayer donc la petite
mare il a hélas il a un peu gratter
comme ça la veille et là on peut manger
les mets dans ma vie le miel mes enfants
puissent voir voilà comment est ce qu'on
fait du miel et comment est-ce que voilà
comment est ce qu'elles vivent comment
est ce qu'elles vivent entre elles dans
une ruche c'est très intéressant pour
les enfants et je pense est très utile
effectivement pour pour parler justement
de la préservation des abeilles qu'un
sujet dont on parle beaucoup aujourd'hui
les fermes de gally ont organisé la
deuxième édition de la fête des abeilles
un week-end pour sensibiliser à la
protection de ces insectes indispensable
à notre alimentation
un tiers de leur mortalité est causée
par le manque de nourriture
à force de faire de la surproduction et
de la productivité agricole
on a fini déjà par changer un petit peu
le paysage
elles ont du mal à s'en sortir
puisqu'elle ne trouve pas une diversité
dans leur nourriture
les jolies fleurs qui sent bon et qui en
plus vont leur apporter soit du pollen
c'est à dire des protéines soit du
nectar qu elles transformeront en miel
c'est la première chose pour les
observer pour les voir et pour les
protéger
une colonie d'abeilles est capable de
butiner + 2 4 milliards de fleurs par an
les fermes de gally invite à créer des
cartes manger dans son jardin ou sur son
balcon pour les aider à se nourrir